My name is Pin Saruta Kiatparkpoom,
and I'm an artist working in metal.
My role involves
reimagining waste material
to create unique pieces of homeware.
I use the scrap metal from
my family's factory, and transform it
into one-of-a-kind items.
This is what my business is all about.
Not all rubbish needs to be thrown away,
some materials can be re-worked
into something new.
After studying fine art, I returned
to my family's metalwork business
to help it grow and develop.
I realised scrap iron was
a versatile material,
so I combined it
with my passion for art and craft.
The thing that's special about my work
is the detailing.
The machines we use create patterns
on the offcuts,
and it's this repetitive detail
that makes my signature style
so unique.
I was born into an industry that isn't
usually associated with art and craft,
but we have the power to change this.
We can learn so much from our ancestors.
I think the new generation
should look to the past
to inform their work.
If we allow the old and new worlds
to co-exist,
the possibilities of craft are
endless. This is my philosophy.
My main purpose is to help others
achieve their full potential.
Craft can transform lives.
I want to create opportunities
for people who work in this industry.
It's important my staff
feel proud of their work,
and have the opportunity
to hone their skills independently
through craft.
I believe that, with the right support,
people can feel empowered at work.
It's essential.
Craft can create positive
change for individuals.
My mission here in Thailand
is to cultivate interest in craftwork,
and demonstrate the importance
of protecting and championing
such a vital industry.